IT'S THURSDAY NERDSDAY!
YEAH!
SO BUCKLE IN, NERDS, BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT GOING ON IN YOUR
WORLD, RESPECTED NEWS
ORGANIZATION TMZ HAPPENED TO
BUMP INTO LATINA ACTRESS
MICHELLE RODRIGUEZ AND ASKED HER
ABOUT RUMORS SHE MIGHT PLAY THE
GREEN LANTERN.
>> I THINK IT'S SO STUPID FOR,
LIKE, EVERYBODY BECAUSE OF THIS
WHOLE, LIKE, YOU KNOW, LIKE,
MINORITIES IN HOLLYWOOD THING.
IT'S, LIKE, STOP STEALING, YOU
KNOW, ALL THE WHITE PEOPLE'S
SUPERHEROES, LIKE MAKE UP YOUR
OWN.
>> Larry: STEALING THE WHITE
PEOPLE'S SUPERHEROES?
YEAH, THAT'S THE TALK I HAVE
WITH MY SON.
SON...
DON'T STEAL.
I KNOW YOU LIKE SPIDERMAN, BUT
THAT'S THE WHITE MAN'S
SUPERHERO.
WE HAVE GIZZARDMAN.
AFTER A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE
OFFENDED BY HER COMMENTS, SHE
GOT ON Facebook TO TRY TO
CLEAN THINGS UP.
>> I THINK THAT PEOPLE SHOULD
STOP BEING LAZY, AND THAT'S WHAT
I MEANT BY MY COMMENT.
AND, YOU KNOW, I'M TAKING IT TO
HEART AS WELL AND I'M
CONSIDERING THIS WHILE I AM OUT
THERE COMING UP WITH PROJECTS TO
DO AND THINGS TO WRITE.
>> Larry: OKAY.
I SEE YOUR POINT.
MINORITIES SHOULD COME UP WITH
ORIGINAL PROJECTS INSTEAD OF
RELYING ON LAZY FRANCHISES.
BY THE WAY, MAKE SURE YOU CATCH
MICHELLE IN THE SEVENTH
INSTALLMENT OF THE "FAST AND
FURIOUS" FRANCHISE, "FURIOUS 7",
OUT APRIL 3rd!
(APPLAUSE)
WELL, HERE'S SOMETHING THAT
WOULD PISS MICHELLE OFF.
THERE'S BEEN SOME LAZY CASTING
TALK ABOUT THE NEW SPIDERMAN.
>> LISTEN, THIS IS NOT SET IN
STONE, GUYS, BUT I'M TELLING YOU
RIGHT NOW, SPIDERMAN'S GOING TO
BE MOST LIKELY BLACK.
BUT THERE IS A CHANCE HE COULD
ALSO BE LATINO.
>> Larry: OH.
(LAUGHTER)
WELL!
THE FANS MAY NOT LIKE THIS, BUT
I TELL YOU WHO WILL LIKE THIS --
MARY JANE.
ONCE YOU GO BLACK SPIDERMAN...
YOU'LL HAVE TO FINISH THAT.
(LAUGHTER)
ANOTHER THING ROCKING THE
NERD-IVERSE -- THE ALL-FEMALE
GHOSTBUSTERS REMAKE.
APPARENTLY NERDS AREN'T AFRAID
OF GHOSTS, BUT THEY SEEM TO BE
FRIGHTENED BY THE LADIES.
>> BUT THERE IS BEEN SOME HARSH
BACKLASH ONLINE ABOUT THE
UPCOMING ESTROGEN POWERED
GHOSTBUSTERS STARRING
McCARTHY, KRISTEN WIIG, KATE
McKINNON AND LESLIE JONES.
ANGRY FANS OF THE ORIGINAL FILM
STORMED SOCIAL MEDIA ATTACKING
THE REMAKE'S DIRECTOR, PAUL
FEIG.
>> Larry: THAT'S HOW NERDS
RIOT, BY THE WAY.
THEY STORM SOCIAL MEDIA.
"THEY BURNT DOWN TUMBLR, MAN!
WHY WOULD THEY BURN DOWN THEIR
OWN?"
BEFORE WE ALL GET MAD AT NERDS,
LET ME SEE IF I CAN EXPLAIN IT
TO YOU.
NERDS DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
WOMEN, THEY HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
CHANGE.
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
NERDS ARE UPSET AT BLACK STORM
TROOPERS IN THE "STAR WARS"
MOVIE.
DO THEY HAVE A PROBLEM WITH A
STORM TROOPER BEING BLACK?
NO, THEY HAVE A PROBLEM WITH YOU
CHANGING THEIR DEFINITION OF A
STORM TROOPER.
LET ME BE A LITTLE CLEARER -- IF
THE FIRST TIME YOU INTRODUCE
OATMEAL TO A NERD, IT HAS MAPLE
SYRUP IN IT, IT BETTER HAVE
MAPLE SYRUP IN IT EVERY
(BLEEP)ING TIME OR IT'S NOT
OATMEAL.
THAT'S YOUR FAULT.
NOW, IF YOU WANT TO CHANGE IT,
YOU NEED SOMEBODY WHO'S PART OF
YOUR ORIGIN STORY TO EXPLAIN
THAT CHANGE.
LIKE WHEN STAR TREK CHANGED
THEIR ORIGIN STORY, THEY HAD THE
ORIGINAL SPOCK COME BACK TO
EXPLAIN IT TO THE NEW SPOCK.
THAT'S WHY NERDS WERE COOL WITH
IT
WELL, THEY WEREN'T COOL, BUT YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M SAYING.
SO THE ONLY WAY TO CALM NERDS
ABOUT BLACK STORM TROOPERS ISN'T
TO RECAST "STAR WARS" BUT TO
HAVE A CHERISHED CHARACTER
EXPLAIN.
EXAMPLE -- LANDO CARLISSIAN
COULD BE TALKING TO ADMIRAL
AKBAR -- "CALM DOWN, EVERYBODY.
IT'S A BLACK STORM TROOPER.
IT WASN'T MY FAULT!"
OR OBI-WAN -- "THIS IS NOT THE
BLACK STORM TROOPER YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR.
MOVE ALONG.
MOVE ALONG ."
OR DARTH VADER -- "I AM YOUR
FATHER AND THE
STORM TROOPER IS A BROTHER AND
THIS IS CNN ."
(APPLAUSE)
OR YODA -- "STORM TROOPER NEGRO!
(LAUGHS)
OKAY IT IS.
BUT LADY GHOST BUSTER, WEIRD IT
IS ."
HERE TO SHED MORE LIGHT ON THIS
SITUATION IS COMIC BOOK NERD AND
BLACK GUY MIKE YARD.
MIKE, WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
>> MIKE: THANKS FOR HAVING ME,
LARRY.
>> Larry: SO WHY IS DIVERSITY
IN SUPERHERO MOVIES SO
CONTROVERSIAL?
I HEARD RUMORS OF A BLACK
BATMAN.
HOW COME THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN?
>> MIKE: NO, THAT DID HAPPEN,
LARRY.
IT WAS ACTUALLY A BIG BREAK FOR
ME.
I GOT TO PLAY BATMAN!
>> Larry: WAIT, THIS IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
YOU PLAYED BATMAN?
>> MIKE: YEAH, WANT TO SEE IT?
>> Larry: HELL, YEAH, I WANT
TO SEE IT.
>> MIKE: ALRIGHT, LET'S TAKE A
LOOK.
♪♪
>> WHAT MAKES YOU THINK THE
GUY'S GOING TO SHOW?
>> DON'T WORRY, HE'LL BE HERE.
♪♪
COMMISSIONER GORDON, I'M HERE.
(BLEEP)!
I'M ON YOUR SIDE!
(SOUNDS OF ARGUMENT AND
FIGHTING)
THIS IS NOT WHAT THE SIGNAL IS
FOR!
>> Larry: WOW.
THAT WAS SHORT.
WAS THAT THE TRAILER?
>> MIKE: NO, THAT WAS THE FULL
MOVIE, LARRY.
>> Larry: OH, I KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED THERE, MIKE.
THEY NEEDED MICHAEL KEATON, A
BELOVED BATMAN, TO COME BACK AND
EXPLAIN THE CHANGES IN THE CAPE
CRUSADER'S ORIGIN STORY.
>> MIKE: NAH.
BLACK MAN LANDS ON A ROOF IN A
MASK, IT DOESN'T TAKE LONG FOR
BAD (BLEEP) TO START HAPPENING.
>> Larry: I FEEL CHEATED.
I WANTED TO SEE MORE!
>> MIKE: ME, TOO!
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN GOING DOWN
TO HIS BAT CAVE, MAKING LOVE TO
RIHANNA AS BAT GIRL, SMOKING BAT
BLUNTS BECAUSE YOU KNOW BRUCE
WAYNE GETS THAT GOOD SCARECROW
WEED.
>> Larry: AND FIGHTING CRIME.
MIKE:  TIME PERMITTING.
>> Larry: WELL, WHAT'S NEXT?
ARE YOU GOING TO MAKE SURE THEY
HAVE A BELOVED CHARACTER TO
EXPLAIN THE CHANGE FOR YOUR NEXT
PART?
>> MIKE: NOPE.
NOT WITH MY NEW ROLE.
LET'S SEE IF THOSE COPS CAN
CATCH BLACK FLASH.
>> Larry: SOUNDS SMART.
MIKE YARD, EVERYBODY!
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.